foreign
's YouTube channel in this session we
will learn how to use update query in
postgres SQL but before we begin let me
tell you guys that we have daily updates
on multiple Technologies if you're a
tech gig in a continuous hunt for latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and don't forget to hit that
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply learn now without further Ado
let's get started with our one point
agenda that is how to use update query
in postgres SQL now we are on the PG
admin flow so that we can execute our
postgrad SQL commands this is similar to
the MySQL workbench which we usually use
for the SQL since this is the postgresql
PG admin is the best one now let's start
our query
so we have the query tool opened
now before we run the update query let's
try to create some tables
so let's create the simple employee
table
so we have the SQL like query here which
is create keyword table keyword and the
user defined table name that is the
employee and the parameters which we
will be having or the column headers we
will be having are employee employee ID
employee Department salary and address
let's execute the command by pressing
the F5 key
there you go the table got successfully
created and next
step would be to add the information
into this particular table
we can use the insert command for the
same
there you go so we are using the same
insert into keywords completely similar
to the SQL queries and here we have
employee table name and the parameters
of the column headers which are the
employee Name ID Department salary and
address so next is the values keyword
and we will be entering the comma
separated values each and every Tuple
right each and every row is separated by
a comma and at the end we don't have to
use the comma because this is the
indication with States this is the end
of the row right now let's run this
particular command by pressing the F5
key there you go now let's quickly check
our table
using the select command select star
from
employee
semicolon
F5 so this is the data that we have in
our table right now now what is the
update query now let's understand the
update query in much more detail here so
this is the set of employees that are
working in your company and let's say
there is some error in certain row let's
say the employee ID is wrong or let's
say you are going to conduct a hike
session let's say Richard performed
really well and Richard meets a height
his current salary is 18 000 and he want
to improvise our upgrade his salary to
twenty thousand right that's when the
update command comes into picture now
let's discuss the syntax or update
command
so the syntax is as follows
we having the update key then the user
defined table name then the set keyword
and followed by that the column name and
the value then we have the WHERE class
now let's say we wanted to improve
reshaps salary so update keyword then
the employee which is the table name
after that we have the set keyword
followed by that in the column name
which is salary equals to value
currently it is 18 000 let's say we want
to increase it to 20 000 then we have to
use 20 000 number in the Value Place
then we have the WHERE Clause followed
by that we have the condition where
exactly what to change it where the
employee ID is equals to
the employee ID of pressure right now
let's practically see that on PG admin
for
there you go we have the update keyboard
employee which is user defined table
name set keyword employee salary is the
column we want to
change then the value will be 20 000
since it is currently 18 000 and a where
condition and the Clause is where
employee ID is equals to 1001 right this
is the ID of Russia now let's quickly
execute this command and see the output
F5 is the shortcut key to execute the
commands in PG admin
and now let's try to execute this
command once again to check if the table
is updated or not
Select Staff from employee
F5 and there you go the current salary
of reshap is
20 000. here it is
so that's how you use the update command
in postgres SQL with that we have
component of this session on postgresql
update command if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
the session then do let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign